Christian
[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
good evening my name is James pronounce
he and him and I want to welcome all of
you here this evening whether you're
here in person or visiting us online I
want to wish you a very very warm
welcome we have a couple of
announcements before we be We Begin uh
first we have for our first Sunday
community meal in August we will be
doing another potluck there will be a QR
code up on the screen shortly use that
to sign up to bring a dish to share
we'll also post the sign up on our at
the table Facebook group so join that if
you haven't
already July is our season of downtime
here at the table we do this to
facilitate a spirit of rest and
recuperation in our community we
encourage our Meetup leaders to take a
break we intentionally schedule few if
any events and few folks who you see
quite often will be taking a break for
the entire month namely Brett Maggie and
Mindy with that in mind we have some
wonderful guest speakers and worship
leaders filling in tonight is a real
treat with Gary Miner leading
worship and char Charles Kaiser
speaking let's take a moment to Center
ourselves and really be present here and
now now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
simplicity Sacred
Space a space for prayer worship and
adoration a space to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your
heart may we all come home
Thanks James all right would you guys
stand with us as we get started for
worship um as you heard my name is Gary
and this is my daughter Noel so we're a
little bit smaller group today kind of
like just you know imagine we're hanging
out in your living room and you know
minus the standing part um but anyways
we're gon to get started
I was
bued
beneath my
shame who could
carry that
kind of
way it was my
T till I met
you I was
breathing but
not her
life all my
failures I
tried to
hide it was my
T till I met
you you call my
name and I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
day you call my
name I ran out of the
Grave out of the
darkness to your glorious day
now your
mercy is
Sav my
soul now your
freedom is
all I
know the old made
you Jesus when I made
you you call my
name and I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness to your glorious
day you call my
name I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
day when I was broken you are my healing
now your love is the air that I'm
breathing I had a f my eyes were open CU
When you call my
name I ran out of that
grave out of the dark
Darkness into your glorious
day you call my
name I ran out of the
[Applause]
gra out of the
darkness to your glorious
day all right okay if there's any kids
here that need to head to your
classrooms now is the time to do that
and we're going to move now into
um a prayer of the people and this is a
moment where you can lift up some Nam
lift up some
situations um and yeah just take a
moment to do that and no's going to go
ahead and get us started on
that for the city of saxi Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and will to conserve it we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for all injured and suffering
we pray to
you for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and and captives and all who remember
and care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection for those struggling with
mental and emotional health we pray to
you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your
presence amen
[Music]
we
hi is there a place we can go where you
cannot find
us there when we
fall there when we rise
nothing is hidden from your
face you know every breath we
[Music]
take your love found us your L found us
we are yours forever your L found us
it's all around us holding us to
together nothing on
Earth above or
below nothing in all the
universe can take us from your
love you came to
us made us your
own you have redeemed us from the fall
you paid the ransom once for
all you love found us your love us found
us we are yours forever your love is
found us it's all around us holding us
together Your Love found us your love
found us we are your
Forever Your Love Is found us it's all
around us holding us
together we will sing because your love
has found us even in the darkest nights
will sing because your love has set us
free we will sing because your love has
f us even in the nights will sing
because you love
us
free found us your love found
us we are yours forever your love has
found us it's all around us haunting us
together your love has found us your
love has found us we are yours forever
your love has found us it's all around
us holding our
together we will sing because your love
has found us even in the darkest nights
will sing because your love has set us
free
we will see
you broke my
chain of guilt and shame and you covered
me with Grace
my life with your
Holy Fire you cover me
with you are the
reaches I am set
free I am set free your
it is for
freom that I
am set
free you broke my chain of guilt and
shame and you covered me with praise
you L my life with your
Holy Father you cover me with
Grace you are the H reaches
out I am set
free I am set free your
oh it is for
freedom and I
am set
free I am set
free I am set free
it is for
Freedom that I
am set
free yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and for your
love
yes Lord we are
grateful for your grace and For Your
Love Yes Lord we are
Love Yes Lord we are are
grateful for your grace and for your
love you are the hand that reaches out
safe I am set free
oh I am set
free it is for for
Freedom that I
am set
free I am set free
oh I am set
free it is for freedom
that I
am set
[Music]
free thanks
guys and um take a moment moment to just
greet the people around you as you get
ready to um hear our message and yeah
thanks for listening
thank you thanks Anna thank you Tech
Team by the way with the slides and the
Great Sound and all that uh I shared
last week that our worship team
rehearses one time and it's 2 o'clock on
Sundays which is miraculous uh but also
our Tech Team shows up at 2m on Sundays
to help support all of the great music
and sounds and everything so can we give
them a
hand they are rock
stars um as James mentioned uh in the
opening July is our time of rest at the
table and it's really so nice to be able
to send Brett and Maggie and Mindy off
uh just into the world for a month and
they can enjoy family time rest time
recoup refresh uh and while we miss them
uh big benefit for us is we get to hear
from some amazing amazing guest speakers
last week we heard from Dr Aaron
brownbrook talking about the story of
Jonah and um this week we get to hear
from Charles
Kaiser
and uh we'll clap for him in a
moment um so and it's it's really a
privilege and a pleasure for me to be
able to uh introduce Charles uh I got to
know him about a year and a half ago uh
through centerpiece and Sally Gary who
some of you know and love and uh he also
spent quite a bit of time with our table
Elder team uh which I was a part of and
uh really gleaned from his coaching his
listening skills uh his knowledge and
just heart for God and heart for people
um and so I'm going to share a bio that
Charles shared with me uh which I ALS
also appreciated and I'll add a little
bit of my own stuff at the end but um
Charles was a pastor in Dallas for 16
years with storyline Christian Community
a network of house churches he helped to
start he was also a Ministry coach for
Brett and the table Elder team for a
year and a half before his family
decided to become members of the table
this
summer Charles and his wife Julie have
three kids Ryan Chloe and Charlie and a
frenetic Boston Terrier Named Gus
Charles is the co-founder of The Healing
Collective a Ministry that creates
spaces for healing religious trauma and
Trauma informing Faith leaders he is
also the DFW Regional area developer for
the Post Evangelical Evangelical
Collective and a word that comes to mind
when I think about Charles is
trustworthy
trustworthy and he has some really
really good and needed stuff that the
church should be and needs to be talking
about and Charles does this with such a
giftedness and empathy and again
knowledge and trustworthiness that it's
really a gift to have him with us today
and also just a gift to have he and
Julie and the kids here Among Us
regularly at the table
and I asked if I could share this he
didn't put it in the bio he's also
written a book so if you're interested
I've got it on my chair it's available
on Amazon it is called trauma informed
evangelism cultivating communities of
wounded healers so without further Ado
please welcome Charles
[Applause]
are you
tired worn out burned out on
religion come to
me get away with me and you'll recover
your
life I'll show you how to take a real
rest walk with me and work with me watch
How I do it learn The unforced rhythms
of
Grace I won't lay anything heavy or
ill-fitting on you keep company with me
and you'll learn to live freely and
lightly good evening everybody uh I am
so excited to get to share a message
with you all and I'm super grateful for
the invitation and I'm super grateful
for um this church you all have been a
safe haven for me and my family as we
have transitioned this year from
pastoral Ministry and we're excited to
get to know all of you um this is kind
of an interesting way to meet um some of
you right now but so hi I'm Charles um
but we're excited to get to know more of
you as we get involved in this community
um I asked Brett if he had any topic or
theme that he wanted me to explore
tonight and um he suggested that I
sermonize about about spiritual trauma
because of my work in that area as Karen
mentioned I've co-authored a book
related to that topic I'm starting a new
ministry related to religious trauma
awareness and healing and so that's some
of what we're going to be talking about
and that feels important to share that
conversation with Brett so that you
don't think that I was super eager to
help everybody be really depressed and
triggered tonight um it's Brett's fault
I was just doing what Brett he's not
here he can't defend himself right you
can take it up with him right uh I'm not
eager to do that and while spiritual
trauma is indeed heartbreaking and heavy
I hope to offer some good news some hope
for anyone here who might be carrying
the burden of religious trauma or anyone
who who loves someone that
does I want to encourage you to take
care of yourself during this time I'm
going to share some heavy
stories uh as a way of a Illuminating
the Dynamics of religious trauma and if
you find yourself activated by any of
what we talk about please know that I
bless you to tune out if you need to to
focus on your breath even to take a
break if that is what you need to do be
kind to
yourself several years ago I was doing a
listening project among my friends in a
board gaming group I'd been a part of
for a few years I was interested to
learn about what makes this community
tick because it was such a significant
source of support and care for the
people that were a part of it and one of
my questions was something like is there
anything spiritual or Transcendent to
you about your experience in this group
uh my friends knew that I was a pastor
I'd been a part of this group for a long
time and so my question about
spirituality wasn't like an evangelism
trick or something um uh many of them
knew me well enough apparently to feel
like they could answer honestly U most
of my friends are also self-described
atheist or agnostic and so predictably
they said something like I don't know I
don't know how to answer that question I
don't really have categories for
Spiritual or Transcendent and then
almost to a
person uh all of them said something to
the effect of but can I tell you about
the terrible things that have happened
to me in religion or in the church
I didn't have language for it at the
time but I was encountering experiences
of spiritual abuse and religious trauma
uh my friends were in the words of Jesus
burned out on religion really burned out
by religion uh not by their own doing
but because they were wounded and
traumatized by others in the name of
religion or in the name of God their
experience surfaced my own wounds in the
context of religion that had yet to heal
I want to share tonight a couple of
those stories as a way of describing
religious trauma and I do so of course
with their permission and um changing
their names to protect their privacy and
well-being Chris grew up in a
fundamentalist Church in West Texas with
a very authoritarian Pastor is the kind
of church that had armed guards at the
doors and was deeply committed to end
times predictions especially around the
year 2000 if you remember
Y2K um these predictions just so happen
to be only available by the Revelation
that was received from the from God to
the senior pastor and this group was so
committed to the imminent return of
Jesus that they discouraged all of the
young married adults in their
congregation from having children
because Jesus is coming any time why why
waste your time it's a it's a it's a
Troublesome and risky time to do that
so
e e
trauma happens when we have this
disconnect when when those are in our
closest relationships when when we feel
um uh powerless or out of control or
like something is happening to us that
we can't prevent and there's no one
there to see us or know us or help us
Chris he lost all of his his closest
relationships the people who would have
been his empathetic Witnesses were the
ones that cut him off and told him you
we'll never see you again and so Chris
started carrying things in his body in
his nervous system because of that
disconnect because of that traumatic
experience another way of understanding
trauma is thinking about it like an
imprint Bessel Vander cul maybe you've
heard of his book the body keeps the
score um talks about trauma as not again
not the thing that happened to us but
the imprint of adverse experiences on
our mind and our brain in our body uh
you can see the imprint in Chris's mind
and body and brain when he sat in the
parking lot and heard worship music and
it it activated this sense of panic this
sense of oh I need to get out of here
because this is this is reminding me of
this past Terror that may will I revisit
it again if I go into this building into
this place of
worship so uh if religious trauma is
also trauma then religious trauma is the
imprint of adverse religious experiences
upon our mind and body and
brain Teresa had two experiences of
spiritual abuse and Trauma in her youth
that led her to leave the church the
first was when a good friend died by
suicide after being sexually abused used
by a Catholic priest in her parish and
in their school the church tried to
cover it up and the second was when her
college roommate almost died by Suicide
and when expelled from her private
Christian University uh the the
administration said uh we don't want
those kinds of students
here and Teresa heard that and witnessed
that and thought I am done with this I
will never again darken the door of a
church building or a religious
institution unless I have to go to my
best friend's wedding or something I'm
done uh Teresa loved Jesus she loved the
way that Jesus looked out for the
outsider and for the lost and for the
outcast and she didn't leave the church
because the church was too much like
those things she left the church because
the church wasn't practicing the very
things that she loved about Jesus but
the depth of those experiences the the
depth of the harm there caused her faith
to be collapsed in and devastated not
only did she lose her connection to
church she started to question if God
really was who God was because of these
experiences in church the trauma
devastated her faith
too U
Teresa's story teaches us a little bit
about spiritual abuse um abuse according
to the American Psych ological
Association is interactions in which one
person or I would add group a person or
a group behaves in a cruel violent
demeaning or invasive manner toward
another person there's usually an
imbalance of power in abuse or one
person or group that has more power uses
that power to harm a person or group
that has less power that power
difference is what creates the
conditions for abuse to occur so
spiritual abuse according to Dr Cindy
Matthews is any abuse that occurs in the
name of religion or the deity of that
religion um so spiritual abuse overlaps
with all different forms of abuse with
physical emotional sexual verbal
psychological all the types of abuse you
can imagine spiritual abuse can come
through any of those Avenues what makes
spiritual abuse distinct is when it
happens in a religious context when it's
motivated by the Bible when it's done by
a spiritual leader when it's connected
to a religious context because it's it
adds this layer of not only is this
person or this group doing this thing to
me um is God doing this to me too that's
the the the spiritual Dynamic there
anytime a spiritual leader is abusive
towards someone else it is always
simultaneously spiritual abuse by virtue
of their spiritual role and
vocation this story of Teresa is also a
good example of secondary trauma U
because you might you might notice that
she was not the direct recipient of the
abuse or the harm in either case she was
she was the one who witnessed it she
loved the people who were harmed um
secondary trauma is the trauma that we
experience when we witness others being
harmed or abused and it can have just as
substantial an impact it can it can get
lodged in our nervous systems just as
deeply as the kind of trauma we
experience when we experience firsthand
the adverse experiences
ourselves Henry grew up in the midwest
in what he describes as a Fox News
Evangelical
Church his dad was the pastor for the
church and Henry realized very early on
that he was gay and when he shared that
with his parents they told him to keep
it a secret because if the church knew
it would threaten his dad's job if he
lost his job would they have to sell
their house would they have to move
somewhere would he be able to get
another job as a pastor and this is a
this is a pre-teen who's having to carry
the weight not only of figuring out his
own own sexuality but also now suddenly
the the financial stability and
well-being of his whole
family uh because of the religious
context that he's in and the the fruit
of that for Henry was all kinds of
Shame all kinds of Shame about who he
was his parents helped J Henry to join a
Ministry focused on conversion or
reparative therapy um to repair
someone's sexuality or convert them from
gay to straight Henry was part of this
ministry for almost 15 years and it
didn't work um in fact some of the
leaders of this very well-known Ministry
told him at the end of his experiences
we never really believed that it would
we've never really thought that
someone's sexual orientation could
change and so added on top of the shame
that Henry felt was a sense of betrayal
and deceit that he'd been lied to by
these people he had trusted himself too
most heartbreaking of all is that Henry
hated himself he ended up leaving church
in adulthood because the shame and the
self-loathing were unbearable and he did
it out of self-preservation totally
understandably Henry's Story shows us
the way that it's not just interactions
between people and or groups and people
that can be a source of abuse and Trauma
um it it's also rooted in the way that
we think and see the world the way that
our imagination takes root in the
institutions and organizations that
we're part of toxic theology toxic ways
of understanding God and ourselves can
be sources of real deep harm and Trauma
diseased theological imagination
you can also see in Henry's story this
Dynamic of complex trauma like the
picture that you saw of the faucet with
the drip drip drip sometimes trauma
isn't just a big traumatic event it's a
series of experiences over time that
cumulatively multiply like compound
interest
multiply this pain in your body and your
life like like the drips of a faucet on
a rock over time that carve a Groove out
of that rock and make a a permanent
impact that's the nature of complex
trauma in a toxic system or culture over
time perhaps you can
identify with one or more of these
stories maybe something like this has
happened to you or to someone you love
uh maybe you've been treated poorly by
the church or Christians in the past
maybe you carry the pain of spiritual
abuse and drama and if that's true I'm
so
sorry I wish that had never
happened that was not your
fault uh telling these stories these are
loved ones of mine it always kind of
Riles up my nervous
system uh and and maybe some of you are
there too so I just want to take a quick
regulation break and invite you to uh to
co-regulate with me our nervous systems
if you need that and just do some deep
breathing with me um just just a few
breaths as if you want to breathe
in Grace and compassion and
kindness and breathe out pain stress and
grief breathe
in breathe out
I'll let you breathe for a
minute spiritual abuse and religious
trauma is not a new phenomenon and we
can see it in the backdrop of Jesus's
words in Matthew 11 several Scholars
believe that when Jesus is referring to
those who are worn out and burned out by
religion those who are weary and heavy
burdened or heavy laden in the versions
we might be more familiar with that the
source of exhaustion and stress is the
demands of the religious leaders of the
day in another text Jesus accuses the
Pharisees of tying up heavy loads and
putting them on people's shoulders
literally heavy burdening
people at least part of what Jesus is
offering relief from here is spiritual
abuse and Trauma that was caused by
religious leaders and religious systems
Matthew 11:28 could just as easily read
are you tired worn out
traumatized by
religion these same religious leaders
Afflicted Jesus with nearly every
conceivable form of abuse in the events
that culminated in his crucifixion
verbal abuse he was mocked and ridiculed
physical abuse he was whipped and beaten
emotional and psychological abuse all
the gaslighting from the religious
leaders that sought to condemn Jesus
betrayal trauma his closest male male
disciples female disciples were great
male disciples
betrayed
Jesus even sexual abuse because Jesus
was hanging naked from the cross this is
like a
voyerism Mane expressions of spiritual
abuse because they never would have
happened had it not been instigated out
of the fear and diseased imagination the
toxic Theology of the Rel religious
leaders who felt threatened by Jesus
they instigated Jesus's crucifixion in
the name of religion and in the name of
God so that means that Jesus is a victim
of spiritual abuse Jesus is a survivor
of religious trauma and contrary to
popular theological
imagination God is not the source of
that spiritual abuse and religious
trauma
God is not the abuser in Chief on the
cross violence in all its forms is
contrary to God's
nature Jesus rather is part of the
Divine Community with mother and spirit
and rather than perpetrate violence they
suffer together the spiritual abuse and
the religious trauma of the Cross they
take this abuse and Trauma up into their
shared life they experience its pain and
death and they transform it into new
life and
wholeness earlier we Define trauma as
what we hold inside in the absence of an
empathetic witness healing then comes
through the presence of an empathetic
witness someone who comes alongside of
us and sees our wounds who hears our
story and Grieves it and laments with us
and says I'm so sorry that should never
have happened that was not your
fault what if this is one of the
meanings of the cross that through the
cross Jesus is an empathetic witness to
our pain Jesus knows what it's like
Jesus suffers with us Jesus is betrayed
with us Jesus
up from the burdens of trauma we're
liberated to reconnect with others as
impoe witnesses to their
pain in other translations of Matthew 11
Jesus refers to his
yoke his yoke is easy and his burden is
light I found it so I found it so so you
might know that song it's old I'm old
it's
old the Yoke refers to a wooden cross
piece that's fastened over the necks of
two animals and it's attached to a plow
or a cart that they would then pull the
First Nations version of Matthew 11:30
captures the sense of the Yoke in its
language where Jesus says walk side by
side with me and I'll share your heavy
load and make it light
in the scriptures the yoke is often a
metaphor for oppression for example in
Isaiah God says is this not the kind of
fasting I have chosen to loose the
chains of Injustice to un untie the
cords of the Yoke to set the oppressed
free and break every
yoke wisdom teachers and rabis would
also use this term yoke to describe
their relationship with their disciples
uh that the way that they were walking
with them to impart their wisdom to them
so Jesus is saying I'm liberating you
from the Yoke of Oppression you've been
under I'm freeing you up from the bonds
of religious abuse and Trauma I'm
inviting you to come under my yoke a
yoke not of Oppression but of healing a
yoke of compassion gentleness and
kindness a yoke where Jesus does the
heavy
lifting and that's not to say that there
is a magical solution a magical
spiritual solution to Healing from
religious trauma we've got to do the
body work where we process the pain of
trauma that's lodged in our nervous
systems that has to be discharged
dislodged and discharged from our bodies
we also need supportive relationships
like our therapists our pastors close
friends who can enter in with us as
empathetic Witnesses and grieve those
harmful experiences with us but we also
need spiritual connection which when it
comes to religious trauma is all the
more important and all the more
difficult to find because those past
sources of spiritual connection became
sources of pain for many of
us Jesus is saying are you burned out by
religion come to me I want to walk with
you I want to lift your burdens I want
to heal your
wounds how will we respond will we
receive Jesus's empathetic witness of
our pain will we receive Jesus's
Liberation his yoke of healing and let
him do the heavy lifting for us you know
what if you're not sure that's
okay if it sounds great but you've had
lots of pain and bad experiences that
make it hard to trust again that's
totally understandable Jesus is gentle
and humble he won't force you to come
but he'll be there for you if you ever
want to
it is time for
communion a few things to know about
communion at the table um we practice
open communion so if you want to
participate uh you're welcome to come
all are welcome and none are
required uh we also go row by Row from
the front to the back and form a line in
the center to receive the bread and the
cup um as you take the cup know that red
is wine and white is juice so you can
choose what you want and you're welcome
to take that with you and return to your
seat some folks like to come up here and
pray at the front um whatever however
you'd like to express your communion
with Jesus in this moment you are
invited to do
so this is the
table not of the church but of the lord
it's it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have
little you who've been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who have failed come because it's
the Lord who invites you and it's his
will that those who want him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
if you're gay and over
85 you fell for your whole life that
when God made you he just messed
up if you've been raised a Southern bell
born and for show and tell but you lie
down feeling never good
enough I'm so sorry
for how it's
been we're broken
artists with broken pens we paint our
pride and call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus to you
[Music]
if you've heard a knock on your front
door but all you found on the porch was
the bastard that just wanted to be
right if you really want to pray to him
but you'll never sure he's listening cuz
who could forgive what you did last
night
tonight I'm so
sorry for what you've heard we broken
poets silly
words we
paint and call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus to
you oh
oh can't you feel him in the
room
oh all he wants is
you I'm so
sorry for all the
wrongs we're broken
singers with broken songs we paint our
pride and call it
truth sorry no one explain Jesus to
you sorry no one explain Jesus to
you I'm sorry no one explain
Jesus
amazing Gra
[Music]
is How
Sweet the
Sound that
save
a like
[Music]
me I want
was
lost but
now I'm
found was
blind but
now I see
[Music]
I want to start off by extending a uh
big thank you to Charles uh for your
powerful words I think another round of
applause would be in
order thank you also to our worship team
uh for leading us through beautiful
beautiful music um and I also o want to
extend a thank you to all of you thank
you so much for joining us this evening
if you are new we would love for you to
fill out a card at the table over there
on your way out or just scan the QR code
on the screens to fill out the online
visitor card that will allow us to F
follow up with you answer questions you
might have and say thank you for
visiting if you are in need of prayer or
general support don't hesitate to find
me after service I would love to be
there for you however I
can as always generosity is a key
component in a life of adoration and
worship to give financially you can scan
the QR code or visit the table tx.org
now I would like to send you all into
your week with this blessing
you are a child of
God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it is true on your
worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved you are worthy you
are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed and we'll see
you next Sunday
[Music]